I mean I like a lot of Pixar movies - I  love Pixar movies yeah like Shrek is my  all-time favorite or like Rio - Oh Rio -  OH  Marva turbo guy oh my god I haven't seen  one of these since we were kids it's so  cool  and my nephew loves this so I think  you'll find these pie charts to be quite  delicious  ah oh my god you're so open fire ahaha  so anyway we're bankrupt so have you  seen ParaNorman I love ParaNorman quick  have you seen hoerlein attack on titan  legibility de Belleville  are real monsters guys can we talk about  Game of Thrones and well night right it  was amazing just looking at you guys see  bubs burgers last night cuz it was so  good Tina she's like my spirit animal  sing for reality she done TLC that's  about the same man anime yeah  like schoolgirls and pinnacle know it's  all about schoolgirls and tentacles it's  like okay to through some batman you  like madmen  you